what was it about each of your
characters that made you guys say yes I
want to be a part of this home because
these comic-book movies are just massive
familiar with david era yes yeah more
than anything it was it was when I found
out that the guy who directed fury was
doing a movie in the DC world I was like
okay they're trying to do something yeah
they're definitely trying to do
something special okay
I want I want to be a part of that I
would say each of the characters kind of
has a badass totem with katana it's her
blade obviously harley has her bat and
boomerang he doesn't his boomerang but
he also has a little stuffed pink
unicorn what's up with that what's up
with it is it was just a little it was
an idea David threw in there one day
that then became like part of the fabric
of this guy's gonna beg Century City oh
yes you've got so many characters and
then playing those characters some of
the biggest actors in Hollywood Cooper
how did you kind of go about wrangling
them on set and then giving each
character literally each one has a
perfect moment to shine in the movie for
me it's all about actors and I feel like
sometimes in these movies the actors get
ignored and I wanted to make sure that
that doesn't happen in my movies and
it's the most important thing for me
watching it there was a definite like
Panther kind of vibe mmm thank you thank
you right inspiration I think you're
right you know sometimes he's snake
sometimes he's a panther other times
he's a hyena he's very much an animal
yeah the laugh right I practice mine
it's not very good let me hear it's
gonna be so bad come on these characters
obviously are anti-heroes but do you
guys think they're bad guys are forced
to do something good or do you feel like
deep down there's really good guy I
think what we're dealing with is that
bad versus evil there is evil
these guys are not really that good you
know we got something in there that it's
making us do what we're gonna do and I
think that's an interesting dynamic of
the movies obviously it is the Suicide
Squad there is a lot of craziness going
on who brought the most sanity to set
sanity I don't know yeah nobody really
rushing what does that mean absolutely
Will Smith I don't know I mean it's not
renewed got any demands out of his
goddamn grounded insanity I was at
comic-con and interviewed Will Arnett
and we talked about Lego Batman and he
said he thought his Lego Batman could
totally take your Joker what do you
think anytime you want to meet the Joker
in a dark alley bring your Legos